the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let's get on with today's lecture
and I want to look at a variety of
different problems different class
different classes of problems we're
going to look at four different classes
of problems and talk about the way you
to go about approaching them we need
very few fundamental laws we're going to
use we use the same fundamental laws
again and again and the issue is really
how do you go about applying them one is
the some this fundamental laws for rigid
bodies so the fundamental laws that are
always true the sum of the external
forces vectors time rate of change of
the momentum of the system with respect
to an inertial frame and we know that
didn't we recognize as mass times
acceleration Newton's second law the
other one is the summation of external
torques and that one is the time
derivative of angular momentum with
respect to a point which you choose this
is an A
plus the velocity of a with respect to
the inertial frame cross with the
momentum with respect to the inertial
frame so that's the torque equation now
we have two special cases of this where
the second term goes away one is when
you are at the center of gravity in
which case by definition the velocity of
that point and the momentum are in the
same direction the cross product
disappears so we there's two special
cases we use all the time when it's
simplifies to that one is when you're at
the center of gravity the other is when
for whatever reason this velocity is
parallel to that and the cross product
goes to zero and sometimes the velocity
is just plain zero so lots of there are
some certain cases that we use lots of
times when that term goes away but
sometimes it doesn't need to have to put
up put up with it
so those are our two fundamental laws
and the question really is how to go
about applying them so I'm going to look
at four four classes of problems
sort of name them right now pure I know
the simplest of heart is pure rotation
about a fixed axis through G through the
center of mass pretty trivial we can all
do those kind of problems a second-class
pure rotation about fix axis at a which
is not equal to G and not at the center
of mass again pretty simple problems
third class no external
I'll call it no external constraints
we'll have to look at you an example to
see how to really mean I will give you
an example right now which will do you
have this hockey puck with a string
attached to it force in this whole thing
is on on a frictionless surface so it's
constrained so it can't go through the
surface but so no external constraints
in the direction that the motion can
happen so this is a 2d problem can move
in the XY and rotation but it's not
touching there's no contains
constraining it in them in the
directions of movement which are allowed
in the problem that's just too much
words to write up here so this kind of
problem and the fourth are problems with
moving points of constraint now though
you won't see a textbook with sections
broken out like this I'm using my own
terminology I just made it up last night
as I was finishing off the lecture but
so you this is just give I'm trying to
give you some insight and this is the
way I think about these things so let's
quickly go through examples from the
first couple of types because they're
especially easy so what are we saying
they're pure rotation about a fixed axis
through G okay center of mass is
somewhere along this axle the axle is
fixed so object can spin around it and
these kind of problems are particularly
simple so I'm not going to dwell on them
but here's class 1 1+1 problems and it's
basically the exact ly rotors of almost
all kinds so for these problems you use
momentum angular momentum with respect
to the center of mass you can express it
as IG times ikx Megha Y Omega Z all
these problems can be expressed with a
moment of inertia matrix times the
rotation vector and it'll give you a
checks hyh D and you can use that second
formula up there the torques
our dhdt so it's through dicks through G
so the second term doesn't appear so to
do these problems some of the C I'll
just give an example here for 2d planar
motion they get especially simple then
for 2d planar motion that means Omega
here is zero zero and we'll let Z be the
rotation axis and this H then with
respect to G just becomes i ZZ omega z
those are the all those 2d planar motion
problems boil down with this and d hg DT
then is eyes easy with respect to G
Omega Z dot or more familiar notation so
all those planar motion problems passing
through axis passing through G like this
does for those problems does this matrix
have to be with respect to principal
axes you have your Xyz coordinate system
to do these to do this style of problem
does that actually have to be expressed
in principal coordinates so that it's
diagonal
doesn't have to be this this you're
worried about rotation about z you'll
find that that statement still always
true now there may be if the thing could
definitely have imbalances and have
unusual other torques that will fall out
on the problem but the for the motion
around the axis of spin this and wertham
where you only have a one Omega Z
component just the one component you
will get it'll work out just fine yeah
some kind of you'll end up with you will
end up with is first of all if you have
a day off diagonal Z terms XE Y Z terms
when you multiply that out you will find
components of H that are in directions
in the Z direction as well as perhaps in
the X&Y and those off those other two
components tell you that H is not
pointing in the same direction as Omega
right and that it tells you instantly
that the thing is dynamically unbalanced
and we'll have other torques that are
trying to bend that axle right so there
will always appear all right let's move
on I want to make sure we get through
this today class two problems these are
basically the pure rotation around some
point that's not through G and for again
though this is a fixed key here is fixed
axis at a it's not moving this is what
makes these problems simpler for these
kinds of problems you do the sum of the
torques with respect to a external
torques
and because that points fix the second
terms don't appear the V cross P terms
and you can write these as I a moment of
inertia matrix times whatever the
rotations are and you would in order to
define the mass moment of inertia matrix
you must have chosen a set of
coordinates attached to the body right
and then with those coordinates you have
computed the moments of inertia for the
body and if you chose wisely
you get principal coordinates and you
only get diagonal entries on the matrix
to chose unwisely you will get other
stuff but it's still a valid mass moment
of inertia matrix it just gives rise you
have to deal with a bunch of other terms
so this will still yield the same answer
how do you get i with respect to a this
is a this is opportunities when you can
use parallel axis yeah
I forgive this excuse me we need to you
need to have finished that out this is
is H so the time derivative of H is the
time derivative of this expression you
have to figure out the moment of inertia
and the rotation rates and you may get
multiple terms only one of which let's
say that this will work out you will get
multiple terms you will get torques that
are not in the direction of spin against
these could be these might be unbalanced
on the other hand it may be for 2d
problems which is sort of common so for
the 2d planar motion which most of the
problems we do are then what your s'what
you would do is you're saying Omega is
say 0 0 Omega Z which simplifies that
multiplying this thing out quite a lot
and if i with respect to G is diagonal
then that means you chose your G you
chose principal axes right then but then
how do you get to i with respect to a
for 2d problems you know really simple
ones how do you get to i with respect to
a that's when you it's the classic case
for using the parallel axis theorem
so for these 2d planar motion problems
and it planar motion problems then you
can use
parallel axis okay we're going to do
I'll do an example so this is kind of a
setup for this an example of this on the
homework what problem on the homework is
just perfect for this it's 2d planar
motion about a fixed point yeah the
cylinder is me and disc with the square
cut out with a pin at the top turning it
into a pendulum
that's the fixed point you can figure
this out you can use parallel axis and
we're going to do an example right now
that's almost identical to that problem
and we started it last time so this the
example I want to work is very similar
it's basically this problem is that
pendulum okay so let's just work it
through quickly we had done the setup
last last time
so last time I basically had derived an
example of the parallel axis theorem for
my little stick here and I'll give you
the some geometry some values so here's
G there's the point I want it to rotate
about a the distance between these two
points is D it's going to pop up in my
parallel axis theorem the got a set of
coordinates here my G is course in the
center of this thing the geometric
Center so I have a and the body fixed
set of axes which I'm going to call Z
and my X is in this direction so that
would make my Y going into the board so
the Y is like kind of like that okay and
this has some properties the dimension
in this direction is a direction and
this dimension is B so it's a got a with
a thickness B and a length L
so when you compute these our symmetry
now so the axes that I've chosen for
this problem are they principal axes all
right perpend there's three three planes
of symmetry in this problem and I've got
one for one principal axis perpendicular
every one of them and all three pass
through the center of mass and they're
orthogonal to one another so those are
conditions are all satisfied for these
to be principal axes for this
rectangular body okay and it's uniform
density so I'll give you the four bodies
like this in your book or any book on
dynamics you can look up then the
properties the I Z Z and we're going to
spin this thing this thing we're going
to have it rotating about 20 years yeah
around the z axis so I'll set it up so
it's what that's the way I've drilled my
holes so it's going back and forth so
the wide part of its this way so i ZZ
with respect to g m l squared plus a
squared over 12 i YY
okay now just to make a point the
dimensions L thirty two point one
centimeters a four point seventy one B
one point two five and eventually my D
this offset the for example where I've
drilled that hole is at ten point two
the point I want to make here lots of
times we could be nice if I could just
make the simplification to call this a
slender rod be able to ignore these a
and B dimensions in this just to get
quick answers you think that's slender
enough so it's about it's not even ten
times the length the width here isn't
even ten it's probably six or seven okay
so the key issue then if you look at
this is really what's the ratio of a
squared to l squared that would tell you
something about the relative relative
importance of the a squared term to the
l squared so let me tell you about that
so a squared over l squared is 0.02 to
be squared over l squared is 0.002 so
even with this kind of fat stick the
approximation of ml squared over 12 is
pretty good it's only 2% off and this
approximation l squared over 12 is less
than two-tenths of a percent off so we
often use roughly slender things we
often times you say ml squared over 12
for spin about their center okay
the we would now need to apply parallel
axis I want to spin this around let this
rotate around not
gee but now around two-point off to the
side so we worked out last time that I
Zizi with respect to a is eyes easy G
plus MD squared so in this so in this
particular problem I have this eyes easy
about gzip Rox Emmitt Li ml squared over
12 so just by way of example to see what
we might find out here is let's let D
equal L over 2 that would be if I move
this one to I put my hole right at the
very top how would this thing behave I
don't have a co hole right at the top
but I have one close okay so let's just
just because the numbers are easy to
work what happens if you put in L over 2
into this formula well then I Zizi
a is ml squared over 12 plus M L over 2
squared is l squared over 4 and that's M
l squared over 3 which is a number
you'll run into again and again and
again in mechanical engineering because
examples like this are used a lot the
mass moment of inertia about a slender
rod pinned at its end ml squared over 3
so let's take this problem - a little
more towards completion that some of the
external moments with respect to a D H
ad T and that's going to be D by DT in
this problem the only rotation is Omega
Z so this is going to be I Z Z with
respect to a Omega Z okay and that just
gives us eyes easy a Omega Z dot or are
familiar it's easy a theta double dot if
you want and we'll make here's an hour
here's our problem it simplifies to this
slender rod and let me do the more
general case here's my rod the pivot
point that it's going around is here
here's this is d still and this is G and
it's swinging with respect to this point
so here's the angle theta so it swings
about this point that you've fixed and
that point is D above the the center of
gravity center of mass so what are the
external moments about this point
there's no torque right at the point but
a Freebody diagram of this drawing this
as a here's a point of rotation here it
is displaced through an angle theta the
weight of the object can all be
concentrated thought of for the purposes
of the Freebody diagram is acting
through G
here's the mass add G gravity acting
down on it and the length of this arm
here that is about which it's swinging
is D so the torque about this is and is
pulling it back - M G d sine-theta
probably you've seen that many times
before including the recent homework and
that must be equal to AI z z about a
theta double dot so we have a new we
have an equation of motion just
collecting the terms together so this is
a oscillator that for this problem has
no external excitation this is its
equation of motion and I need a theta
double dot okay but is it linear is it
linear kunos not a linear equation of
motion but for sure it is an oscillator
right and for anything that vibrates you
can lots of nonlinear problems that
exhibit vibration they you can think of
them you can pose problems where you say
okay what's their static equilibrium
position and think of a very small
motion about that static equilibrium
position
you can always linearize about the
static equilibrium position and be able
to come up with linearize equation of
motion that at least from that you can
calculate the natural frequency of the
system for small motions around its
linear around its static equilibrium
position so in this case that's pretty
easy to do and you've seen it before for
small theta sine theta is approximately
equal to theta so we are going to
linearize the equation this theta equals
0 is the static equilibrium position so
we're linearizing around zero and round
zero that's the approximation so you
just substitute that in ICCA
theta double dot plus m g d theta equals
zero
there's your linearized equation of
motion I want an estimate of the natural
frequency so you know find Omega n so
this is basically entering into solving
differential equations but I let mother
nature tell me what the answer is
I do the example and I say it oscillates
looks a lot like sine Omega T to me all
right
plug in china mega t let's find out some
theta amplitude sine Omega T plug it in
so you plug that in and you get minus
Omega squared is easy a plus mg D and
all of this you can factor out the theta
zero sine Omega T equals zero so what
you get and general theta that's not
zero L so you have a trivial problem not
moving at all but in order for this
equation and this can be any anything
between zero minus one and plus one
depending on the time so in order to
satisfy this equation this part inside
of the parenthesis has to be zero and
when you just solve that you find that
Omega squared equals
M G D over eyes easy a and the reason
I've gone to the you know bother of
working this out in detail right to the
end is that every one degree of freedom
rotational oscillator that you will ever
encounter sticks wheels with static
imbalances show you this one it's an
oscillator to any one degree of freedom
oscillator rotational oscillator
pendulum basically all pendulum this is
the formula for the natural frequency so
it's going to be of that form for any
pendulum so any one DOF pendulum this is
the generic answer so that cut out
problem for today has to come down to
this where this is the distance between
the mass Center and the point of
rotation and that's your mass moment
inertia about the point of rotation so
it's worth kind of knowing that one okay
keep moving
now things begin to get interesting the
these latter two classes are are harder
conceptually but once you have a
solution method for them they're not all
that hard
this one is one of the problem I
described at the beginning we've got
this hockey puck like thing and a string
wrapped around it pulling on it with a
known force in this problem they call it
a hundred and fifty Newtons the mass of
this thing is 75 kilograms the it's on a
frictionless surface okay and we want to
find its acceleration of the center of
mass and the rotation of the center of
the center of mass so find theta double
dot and find the linear acceleration
that's basically the name of the problem
and they give you that it's 75 kilograms
150 Newtons and
Kappa the radius of gyration is 0.15
meters this is defined as the radius of
gyration so what's what's that it's the
radius of gyration is really appropriate
really only useful about for mostly 2d
rotational problems around 1x around an
axis of rotation and what it means is
this is the distance away from the
center of rotation at which you could
concentrate all of the math and have the
same mass moment of inertia okay
so this this has here's G here at the
center uniform disc we know that there
is an i ZZ about G for this problem and
I need to pick a coordinate system so we
talked about things here get em out of
the center so I'm going to let Z be
upwards and because I'm looking ahead
and want to keep the equation simple I'm
going to make my x-axis here parallel to
F so I only have to deal with one vector
vector component equation and then that
makes the y-axis this way okay so I'm
interested in eyes easy because I'm
spinning around the z axis I know that
for a uniform disk that's the principal
axis is the vertical one and what I'm
saying is that you can then set find
there's an i ZZ of g that is can be
expressed as M Kappa squared so Kappa in
effect is just as easy G over m square
root now why do we use that kind of
thing
well the the way this problem was set up
I actually took it out of a book it with
this it wasn't a uniform disk you'd say
it's a pulley wheel or something and
it's got spokes in here and a rim it's
still axially simply it still has some
axial symmetries but it's getting a
little messy it's hard for you you can't
just say that's mr squared over two it's
got some other mass moment of inertia
about the center but it's got holes and
stuff in it because of the spokes so
oftentimes you'll be given the mat the
radius of gyration because it's a little
difficult to give you a mathematical
description of what the actual as easy
is
that's often why you do it and it's
saying is you can measure rather than
try to calculate you can actually just
measure the mass moment of inertia of
something so how would I measure my I
say I didn't know any formulas but how
would I measure the mass moment of
inertia of this in the Z direction what
experiment would you do she says apply
torque measure the angular acceleration
hang a weight off of it known weight
wrap a string around it known mass known
G known torque around the center measure
the angular acceleration I fade a double
dot equals the torque
you know the torque you know the measure
the theta double dot calculate I I
equals I'm Kappa squared and you could
just say well Kappa for this system is
okay that's that's how you use it I'll
give you an example really hard to
calculate mass moment inertia a marine
propeller you actually do want to know
the mass moment nourish about its center
for purposes of torsional oscillations
on the shaft etc hard to calculate
pretty easy to measure okay so how many
degrees of freedom does this problem
have well when we say it's 2d it's a
rigid body but it's 2d which means it's
lying on a plane it's a planar motion
problem it only allowed to rotate in Z
not allowed to rotate in around the x
axis or the y axis so there's two rigid
body six degrees of freedom possible
there's two immediately that you said it
can't rotate so we're down to four
it cannot cannot translate in the Z
direction right we're down to three okay
so that believes us what so the degrees
of freedom for this problem is six minus
three constraints is three that means we
have to have three equations of motion
and they would account for what are the
possible another way of saying this what
are the possible
motions now this problem XY and Z or
rotation in Z okay
so now we've set the problem up now to
go about solving it we need let's do we
need a Freebody diagram so here's my
disk here's the force any other and
there's certainly has weight in the z
direction but we're not there's no z
acceleration so in the plane of the
board that's the only external force is
acting on this right okay there's our G
now this problem and I'll say generalize
on this in a few minutes this problem
can be always be restated as recast let
me put it that way as here's your point
G with a force acting on the center of
mass see this force doesn't go through
the center of mass this force goes
through the center of mass I'm going to
replace that problem with this problem
pure moment acting about the center of
mass problem so you can always make this
transition and I'll do the general case
for you in just a minute but you can
always do this so that's kind of my
second point here third point we need
then this is our free body diagram we
need our apply our laws of motion so
some of the forces in the Y are now
remember this is Z coming out of the
board
y this way X this way some of the forces
in the Y 0m acceleration of G in the Y
Direction zero so you know there's no
acceleration in the Y so we saw it has
three degrees of freedom
that's the first equation of motion give
you a trivial result so y double dot is
there
that's your first equation of motion
then you have a second equation of
motion sum of the forces in the
x-direction equals just our F I hat it's
positive x-direction because we were
clever and how we set up the coordinate
system and that's got to be M X double
dot I hat direction so we know right
away that X double dot is the force F
divided by M and that's 150 Newton's
over 75 kilograms or 2 meters per second
squared all right the third one then is
the moment of inertia with respect to G
in this problem the m'excuse of the
angular momentum is some i CZ g times
omega z and that's what we're looking
for so this is another way of izg G
theta dot k hat direction and we're
going to apply that the external torques
sum of the torques is d H with respect
to G DT and that's going to give us i ZZ
g theta double dot
so this third class of problems you are
best just working with respect to the
center of mass that's kind of the point
here there's no there's notes not know
contours of contact
there's just known external forces you
have to deal with them do your work with
respect to the center of mass so we have
force equations we have moment equations
and basically you're you know you know I
Zizi for this problem is Kappa squared m
and you're given m and you're given
Kappa so you can now and what we have to
actually last thing left here is to
figure out the torque what's the torque
well it's our in this direction crossed
with F in that direction so it's our J
cross with F I J cross I - right RF -
our F okay hat so you can now solve for
theta double dot as RF over eyes easy or
RF over M Kappa squared
and that says - says it's rotating this
way which is what you'd expect
right now I've meant to ask you a
question before we started but to think
about this about it right at the
beginning and said okay this is the
problem if I grab this string and pull
in this direction will there be any
motion in the Y direction
if I meant to start that way I'm really
kicking myself for not doing that
because a lot of people think that
there's possible that it can move off in
the Y direction because it's not being
loaded symmetrically you're pulling on a
side then people think it'll kind of try
to move away like that it doesn't does
it okay
so an important generalization we've got
a rigid body you have a force acting on
it has a mass center here so
perpendicular to that force is some
distance okay
we'll call it D you can always equate
this problem to and set it up as force
conceptually you can think of it as
equal and opposite forces which cancel
one another this is like I've done
nothing to this problem and then a force
acting at this distance F this is our
distance D so this problem is identical
for that problem I've just added and
taken away two more forces right so the
total forces on the system are still F
and there's still an F operating in a at
a lever arm D but now if I put these two
together they are equal and opposite and
they form a couple a moment acting like
that so this is equivalent to here's G
with an F on it and a moment M naught
okay and this M naught is my D cross F
so that's the generalization for what I
did up here I mean I went from that to
that and this is why you can do that
okay and so there's a if there's a gent
now if you have an object and lots of
different forces acting on it this is fi
down here
and here's G you can draw a radius from
G to this point so I'll call that R i
with respect to G then two way to
generalize this is that this is equal to
some F total and a moment acting at G
okay and all that you have to do there
is F total is the summation of the F is
vector sum and the mg the M with respect
to G here is the summation of the r i
with respect to G cross Fi so that's the
Jets the generalization for multiple
forces on a body so you are making an
equivalent force acting at G and a
moment acting at G and I shouldn't call
this little G that's really confusing so
that's the generalization when you need
to do problems like this okay
catch your breath while I scrub a board
here now we got to move on to these
class Philip its class four problems
moving points an example is that truck
problem that you had known acceleration
so there's two common ways of doing this
problem you can do this problem by
summing forces at the center of mass of
that pipe and summing moments around it
but the moment around this comes from a
friction force here what you don't know
so that introduces an unknown that you
have to then solve for so if you work
around G for this pipe you can do it you
can work around G you could say some of
the moments around G sum of the forces
spec to G but you have to deal with
unknown forces so you're working with
respect to G implies unknown forces e
eat for example friction so you'd really
maybe rather work around the point of
contact a because if you some of your
moments about a the friction force has
no moment arm and you know it doesn't
appear in the answer all right
so but this gets trickier this is more
this is a little more
sophisticated I'll just call it step and
you need to do this you need a little
theorem so to work with respect to a you
need to be able to say that the angular
momentum with respect to a it's you now
are working around a moving point maybe
accelerating it's very handy to be able
to say it's the angular momentum around
G which is easier to calculate plus our
G a the distance from the center of mass
to the point you're working on cross the
linear momentum of the system with
respect to the inertial frame we need
this so this is a formula we need and
let's see why this is true I think this
is sort of thing you know that's is the
formula to come out of the blue here and
why is it true so I don't use you like
to do proofs but the proofs of this in
on the board but the proof of this is
really quite simple
here's a little mass point MI and this
radius is R of i with respect to a this
is R of G with respect to a and
therefore this is our of i with respect
to G is this one and we know that this
Plus this gives us that so we can say R
I particle i with respect to a is our G
with respect to a plus r i with respect
to G all vectors
so the angular momentum of that body
which is from the basic definition of
angular momentum is the summation of all
little mass bits of the RI with respect
to a across the linear momentum of each
little mass bit but we can expand that
with that sum so this is the summation
of my our G with respect to a plus our i
with respect to G cross P I owe
summation over all the mass bits I'm
going to expand this and I can expand
this into this times that summations of
this times that and this times that so
that becomes a our G a cross summation
of a puts Pio this is a little M is V I
with respect to O each one has velocity
each one has a mass so this is mi V I
with respect to O plus the summation R
IG s
cross mi v io s now notice I pulled this
one outside of the summation that's
because this is a single this is a fixed
number it doesn't change in the
summation it's just the distance from my
starting point to G so I can pull it out
and do the summation and then do the
cross product what is the summation of
all the m/v is for the body
that's the momentum of each little
particle add them all up what do you get
this is our G a cross P with respect to
O that's this term and this is all the
little distances from the center of mass
to the cross with the momentum of each
little one what's that
well this is it this looks like a
definition of angular momentum this is
the angular momentum of every little
mass particle with respect to G add it
up this is H with respect to G which is
what we set out to prove so the H with
respect to a is H with respect to G Plus
RG a cross the linear momentum of the
body yep he I respect I mean the
velocity
you got to get in there
but instead of writing out our as a son
can write out the velocity as the sum of
the respect to the origin are you know I
H the definition of angular momentum
yeah
the velocity and you can figure out if
you had a momentum visual piece and
multiplied by RI a that's that is the
angular momentum with respect to a but I
broke it apart so that I could show you
that this formula I want to use has two
pieces why I use that okay so then if I
can use that it's easy to get HS respect
to G sometimes it's really hard to know
what to do around it with things that
happen around this point a so now let's
go back I think to understand this we
need to go back to our truck problem we
now have a formula that you know where
it comes from we have our truck that is
accelerating at x1 double dot and we
want to find out what the what's theta
double dot for that pipe what's it doing
so first we needed some kinematics and
in particular what is the x2 I don't
know label this very well it didn't so
here's my pipe here's my truck bed that
it's in contact with trucks moving at x1
double dot we know the in an inertial
frame the movement of the center of mass
of my pipe is x2 and it has some angular
rotation rate I'll call or angular
rotation I'll call theta so the movement
of this guy I need to be able to express
in terms of x1 and theta
well if this is fixed to the truck and
you just the truck move forward then X 2
would be equal to x1 but in fact it
rolls back a little bit and the distance
this point moves if it rolls through an
angle theta is it rolls backwards and
amount are theta
and we're going to need to take two
derivatives of that x2 double dot equals
x1 double dot minus R theta double dot
so that's the little kinematic
relationship we need to do this problem
next we apply I need to apply a physical
law which is the one I've derived so
this is our physics here now our
physical law and that's that the
external torques D H respect to a DT
plus V AO cross P oh and in this case is
there is this na is VA o zero now in
fact it's x1 dot right it's in the i
direction
how about what direction is P the
momentum of the pipe
we move in the Y direction up down it
only moves in the X so this velocity is
only in the X this is in the X where I
had direction this cross product is zero
so it just happens that they're parallel
so this thing goes to zero you don't
have to deal with it that's because
these guys are parallel parallel motion
but you did have to consider it you did
if the think about it it's not just
trivially zero okay so that means that
the torques about a is just DHA DT and h
a for this problem is I well it's H G
which is eyes easy G theta double dot
but I have to put in this set theta dot
excuse me this is just the H I have to
put in the second term R G with respect
to a cross P with respect to O so here's
my H a now to write it again up here
this is as easy G theta double dot theta
dot in the K and now this second term R
is RJ my y-axis is up the radius of this
thing is R is the radius so the moment
arm is RJ crossed with the linear
momentum of that piece of pipe which is
the mass of the pipe times X 2 dot in
the I Direction J cross I is minus K so
I Zizi
expected G theta double dot theta dot I
keep taking the derivative a little too
soon okay
- our mx2 dot K and now some of the
torques D by DT of H with respect to a
take the derivatives eyes easy G theta
double dot K minus R M x2 double dot K
unfortunately none of these unit vectors
are rotating so we don't have to deal
with any of that and I'm almost to the
end but now I have to go back to that
original kinematic relationship which
set allows me to express x2 in terms of
x1 + R theta and if I substitute that in
here and solve for it I get theta double
dot equals M R over Y Z Z G Plus M R
squared X double dot whole thing x1
double dot
so you've accelerated x1 double dot the
thing starts rolling in and actually
throwing backwards which is the plus
theta direction at this rate we did this
using this formula for H a now the
beauty of this formula is that it works
for moving points a points that are
moving he even can be accelerating all
sorts of nasty conditions true it's
based on the fundamental definition of
angular momentum so the book yeah make
sure
in this first line here on a fiscal wall
that that stroke doesn't mean that V sub
a was zero event that that term this
term zero because these happen to be
parallel cross product is zero in this
case if it had not turned out to be
they were different directions got to be
a nonzero term and you would have to
bring it along and take its derivative
along with the other stuff okay but this
is a really powerful method now the book
is reasonably good in lots of points but
in Chapter 17 when it does problems that
are kind of like this it introduces
something I find it hard to digest what
they're doing as particularly where's
Matt there's equation 1715 when you get
to that bit of the book just ignore it
use this method okay the author tries to
give you kind of a little trick that you
can use but the probability ryx is you
have to memorize them so what I've shown
you today is on this a based on basic
definition of angular momentum that
expression to the top is always usable
not just special little conditions which
is what is the formula in the book is
generated for we've got a couple of
minutes let let you ask questions and
then I'll just pose a conceptual problem
or two and ask you what method you'd use
yeah
oh you know boy
I'm planting contact in order to be able
to do this good enough if we're going to
know something here right important
catch thank you why is this true
so we chose it why we chose to work
around point a with respect to that
point there are no external forces that
create moments on that pipe with respect
to that point and that's why you can say
that the time derivative of this angular
momentum is equal to zero because there
are no external torques if you had
picked any if you pick G to do this
problem with the sum of the torques
about G be zero no you'd have to put
that friction force in there and have RF
and figure out F is we completely
avoided having to calculate the friction
force that's the point of being able to
use techniques like this and can make
your computations around points of
contact okay
the so what so that your textbooks have
lots of problems like this you've got a
box on a cart you're kids pushing it and
it gets a little exuberant and pushes a
little too hard accelerates the cart a
little too fast and the Box falls over
and breaks the lamp or whatever's in it
all right and if you if it's this way
and I accelerate it it's much more
tolerant falls over easier this way but
if I asked you gave you a problem and
said calculate the maximum acceleration
that I can put on this object such that
it just barely want to just right at the
edge of tipping over but doesn't tipping
over what's that maximum acceleration
that you don't tip
what method would you use one I do the
three three kind of four classes of
approaches to problems
she I here for anybody else want to bid
here's more for with three work why he
says three would be complicated three
means taking moments and forces with
respect to the center of madness if you
do that what do you have to deal with in
this product you have to have to then
around the center of mass there's a
friction force there's a normal force
pushing up here and the way you do this
problem is you just where it's just
barely about to go all of the forces
pushing on this corner burial think of
it it just it lifting up a fraction you
know all of that contact point moves to
right here you have an upward force and
a friction force and then they create a
moment about G but if you do the forces
around G you have to solve for those two
you do the forces around a the trick
here is figuring out where is a but if
you realize a is right here and you do
what we just did this problem just piece
of cake